welcome to the ddps seminar everyone
before we introduce our invited speaker
let's go over some rules and Logistics
uh first of all please mute yourself
during the talk but if you have
questions you can unmute and ask
questions or use chat room to post your
questions so that we can address them in
Q&A session at the end second today's
ddps seminar is open to external
audiences uh therefore no classified
discussion is allowed so please watch
out uh finally The Talk today will be
recorded and uploaded in our YouTube
channel that's about it now let me
briefly introduce our speaker today it
is an honor to host Dr Jin longu who is
an assistant professor in the department
of mechanical engineering at the
University of Wisconsin at medicon uh
the current research of his group mainly
focuses on developing datadriven methods
to to learn closure models for complex
dynamical systems for example multiscale
multif physics and chaotic systems from
direct and indirect data uh before
joining U ww M medicine he was a
research scientist at ctech working on a
datadriven climate modeling project he
got his pH PhD degree in aerospace
engineering at Virginia Tech in
2018 and his dissertation is about using
basian inference and physics informed
machine learning in turbulence modeling
today Jin Long Will present an exciting
topic which is datadriven closure
modeling using derivative free common
methods I'm sure we will hear an
exciting talk today but before I pass
the button to jinong let me ask a couple
of question whichin long just to get to
know you better and to make this uh
seminar somewhat informal
obviously um you're passionate about
data enclosure modeling in general is
there any moments in your life when you
realize that wow this is it this is the
field I would like to commit my career
if you can share that
moment yeah I developed the interest
along this direction during my P study
so at first I joined a group maining
focus on the computational food Dynamics
research the just records one of the
focus of the research is turbulance
modeling and existing turbulance
models uh I would say many of them are
not good enough for real applications
and that motivate us to see okay given
the fact that data amount is increasing
rapidly in past few decades can we
Leverage some data D modeling techniques
try to help the uh
predictability of the existing models
and that actually needed me to further
explore this direction yeah awesome
awesome um last question second question
I understand that you are studying your
career as an assistant professor um
although it was short would you share um
your experience being a professor at a
good or bad uh it's very good very good
okay yeah yeah all right and research
here is fantastic yeah fantastic and a
lot of collaborations with the uh within
the faculties and the other other
department as well I guess yeah yeah
awesome awesome all right sounds good
the stage is yours
T thank you very much for the
introduction and the questions so so
thanks again for the invitation uh today
I'm going to share some recent Works
about data driven closure modeling using
dtive free common
methods so the general motivation of
this direction of work can you see
my no somehow it's gone okay can you see
the screen yes okay so the general
motivation of this direction of work is
try to improve the modeling of complex
dynamical systems for example the Earth
system uh some energy harvesting or
Rover on mars or some kind of complex
physical systems involved in engineering
appti and a common kind of feature of
all these systems is that they often
involve multiscale or multi physics
processes for which we cannot afford to
numerically simulate every
details for example if we take a look at
the Earth system we will have the cloud
microphysics at
millimeters up to the planetary waves
can be 10,000 kilometers so with this
large range of scales it would be almost
impossible to to simulate every details
within this system and that's why fure
models are usually needed for some
unresolved degrees of
freedom and the talk of today the main
focus would be to answering a question
how to improve closure modeling for
complex dynamical systems by using some
data driven methods
okay and Before Time into the details I
like to briefly introduce what do I mean
by closure problem so let's assume that
if we have the original system uh follow
this kind of general form of
OD and in practice the original System
state U small U
here almost kind of involve a very high
dimensional space and simulating every
details of that would be very very
expensive and and in practice what
people would like to do instead of
directly solving this equation for real
engineering Pro uh problems people will
try to introduce some reduce order state
capital u the methods to introduce this
kind of Ren order State include for
example C screening is a or more
recently Auto encoder once we decide
what kind of reduce order State we want
to work with it will not be difficult to
derive the corresponding govern equation
for this capital u but the problem is
that for the original Dynamics f is
usually nonlinear which means that the
derived exact form for this reduced
order State usually not only involve
itself but also involve some
misinformation carried by the unresolved
original System state so the closure
modeling means that we want to propose
approximation of f Thea that only depend
on the information that we simulate
which means the capital u here and hope
that the foda can well approximate the F
Bar the exact Dynamics for this reduced
order state but in practice we know that
it is not usually the case that F Thea
can approximate f B very well and that's
why in recent years people start to
think about a question can we quantify
the difference between these two F Bar
and F Thea with an additional term M and
M basically characterize the error made
by F Thea and the next question is that
can we use some data to help us
determine what will be a good M should
look like
so typical choice would be what people
call Direct data which means that with
the pair data information about U and
the true evaluation of M on the
corresponding U if we have this kind of
data pairs we can directly use standard
regression methods to Trend this
unknown uh error
term but if we want to use Direct data
to achieve that that means that we need
to estimate the evaluation of M on
some System state capital u that involve
either we evaluate this kind of
difference we use the temporal
derivative minus the approximation of
TAA or we can directly use the
difference between F Bar and F Thea to
help us get the data about the M
evaluate on some you but both approaches
they share some issues in
practice the first
approach if we want to get a good
approximation about the tempor to here
is usually not practical because real
data may be noisy or even sparse in time
which means that estimating this term
accurately is sometimes difficult in
practice on the other hand getting the
fbar in order to assess the difference
between this two will involve simulating
the original system and get the
information of small U
unresolved I'm sorry to interrupt there
is a question from shedi I think it's
better to answer that right now um yeah
so he ask about the what is the Begger
superscript refer to oh deer indicate
that the system State corresponding to
the true system so you can think that
whenever we put the dger here we mean
that this U is gathered instead of
simulating this approximate system is
gathered either by an sensor from the
true system or if we have some high F
dat simulation and we postprocessing to
get the corresponding capital u for the
true
system
okay and as I mentioned that those kind
of approaches if we want to use direct
data which means you and M evaluate on
you as training data pairs we will
encounter problems in practice and that
is the main reason that motivates us to
think a alternative approach instead of
using regression standard techniques to
kind of chin this eror term can we just
use some interact data so which means
that we just have some observation about
the true reduce order System state
capital u and instead of assuming that
we can directly get the corresponding
valuation of M on UD dagger we just rely
upon this kind of indirect data can we
try to get a good form of M and
calibrate it so this talk will focus on
the use of this type of data what we
called indirect data and I will mainly
demonstrate the learning of this unknown
Arrow term by using what we called
command
version so next slide I will Briefly
summarize some key features about The
Ensemble coming version eki which is the
optimization method we use to help us
calibrate that unknown err
term so the English problem we try to
solve in general form can be view is the
top equation here we have some data Y
and we also have some forward map G that
map the unknown printers Theta
to the data space and ETA here just
characterize the noise associated with
the data generation process and eki
formula is ative formula and J here
indicates the index of Ensemble and M
represents the index of eki stat so for
the M's eki step if we look at here we
will have the current test
about unknown parameters
Theta and then we will be able to plug
in the current estimation into the for
map such that we will get the
corresponding result in data space we
know that current estimation may not be
good enough which means that comparing
to the true data there will be some
mismatch between these two and then we
first use a normalization factor try to
normalize this mismatch a little bit
here gamma just indicate the cence of
the noise and the capital g g letters
here indicate the
cence within the data space produced by
the forward model G and we first
normalize this data mismatch in data
space and then we have another conance
Matrix between the parter space and the
data space and we use this to project
the
normalized mismatch back to the
perimeter space and use that to adjust
our current estimation about Theta and
then that will give us the result for
the Theta estimation for the next eki
step and we will do that iteratively
until we achieve some statistical
convergence and at the bottom I just
briefly list a few advantages of using
eki the first point is that as you may
have noticed that for this updating
formula all we need to access is the
Ford map G evaluation we don't require
any gradient information about the Ford
map G which means that the method that
we present here is is a dtive free
optimization method and also in practice
people find that The Ensemble coming
version just because is Ensemble based
method it tends to be robust to noisy
evaluations of the forward map G and
also the core task here actually is
equivalent to a convex optimization
problem which means that we can easily
incorporate some additional constraints
into this optimization
process and for the third part I will
revisit that in more details for the
second part of this talk but before that
let's get to the first part of this talk
uh the data driven turbulance closure
modeling so as we already know that
turbulence actually is ous in many types
of flows and in practice Renos average N
Stokes the r models are still widely
used in turbulence simulations even
though they have limited predictive
capability for complex
flows so if we take a look at the r
equation we will see that the only term
needs to be modeled is sitting at the
right hand side here is what we called
Reno stress how and the difference
between the true Reno stress and the Rin
model Reno stress is usually unknown to
us if we can characterize this
difference in a relatively accurate way
and then we can use this difference to
help us further improve the predictive
capability of the Rin simulations
okay and the general goal of this kind
of part is try to propose a pipeline
help us to characterize the difference
between these two and use that to
improve the r simulation and the example
that I'm going to use is what we called
flow over periodic heels and the
geometry of that flow is presented at
bottom so we have solid wall on top and
at bottom and the general flow direction
is from left to right
and we have periodic boundary condition
for both Inlet and
outlet and we assume that we have some
sparse
measurement of the renal
stress
uh sorry the res modeled velocity
U and the goal here is try to estimate
the full field Ren stress diseny what is
the DAT to to here which means that as
long as we have some data as fars in
space about the capital u here can we
try to estimate the Delta tow as the F
field and if we can do that we can use
that to help us improve the Rens model
Ral stress and then we can prove the
simulation results of the Rin okay so
that will be the general goal and before
diving into the details of the results
I'd like to briefly go through the
summary of algorithm so at beginning we
assume that we can sample some
realizations about the Delta tole the
real stress discy from some prior
distributions and then we'll have some
Ensemble of the Delta
tole with that we can plug in this
Ensemble initial points about the Dela
tow into the for model of the Rand
solver and then we can try to simulate
to get the corresponding velocity field
U capital u here and then we can compare
the simulated velocity with the
observation data which is just sparse
velocity at certain locations and we use
the difference between these two to help
us update the estimation about The
Ensemble of Delta to and we do that
atively until we achiev some statistical
convergence about the delat
tole so behind this uh General pipeline
actually what we're doing here is the
patient inference so assuming that we
have some brii distribution about dat to
and this SPS observation provide us some
likelihood model about the probability
of observing those velocity on those
points condition on the given Delta tole
and then with this two we want to
evaluate the posterior distribution
which means that the probability
distribution of Delta to given the
information of the velocity of ation on
those sparse points
okay and here actually there is a
question I haven't answered yet is that
at first we assume that we have some PRI
distribution that we can sample The
Ensemble of Delta tow that will be the
starting point of this algorithm and the
natural question would be how can we
construct this prior distribution for
the datat tow so for the next slide I
will briefly introduce how we construct
the PRI fustion of the data to so in our
work the PRI is modeled as a gion
process with the cence
Matrix uh in this detail form where the
square exponential kernel and the prior
knowledge is used to specify the field
of variance which is just the sigma here
the sigma is a f with inputs as the
spatial
coordinates and for this specific flow
we know that the r models tend to
perform not good in this free sh region
and also this recirculation region and
that's why we empirically assign larger
values for the FI of variance for this
Sigma and after that we can use what we
call kahun expansion try to get the
corresponding basis functions that we
can use to reconstruct the gion random
FEI of the data to so at the bottom I
present several leading components of
the candidate basis functions and by
linearly combine these different modes
and then we can have different
realizations of this gion random fute
for the data
tole and that is equivalent to to see
that the remaining task is try to
estimate how would be the optimal way to
linear combine all the spasis functions
such that we can have a good data
to and more rigorously that means that
we parametrize this data tow by using
the basis functions we obtain from the C
love expansion and we line combine them
together using some coefficients set and
the remaining task is given the sparse
observation data about the velocity we
want to estimate the posterior
distribution of unknown perimeter set
given the information of this sparse
observation of velocity okay so with the
brief introduction about the algorithm
i' like to show some results about this
specific case so on top we have the
prior distribution of the simulated
velocity fute on some vertical
profiles and on the bottom we present
the posterior velocity Distribution on
the same vertical
profiles here the green lines indicate
The Ensemble of the simulation so each
line correspond to a different
realization of the dat
and blue lines here correspond to the
SLE mean and red lines here correspond
to the Baseline R results which means
that we just use a existing res model
without correcting it and black lines
here correspond to the direct numerical
simulation data which is high F
simulation we view as the choose and
black crosses indicate location that we
put the sensors such that we can get
the corresponding velocity data on those
points and as we can see that if we
sample Delta tole from the PRI solution
and plug in to the for solver we will
get the scattering velocity profile for
the simulated velocity on every point
and we also have the scattering with the
Baseline Rin uh approximately sitting in
the m
and if we incorporate data and try to
estimate the optimal choices for those
unknown perimeters Theta that help us
characterize the data tole field and
then the updated velocity Feud using the
posterior distribution of the Delta to
is presented at bottom as we can see
that in many regions especially the
circulation region we achieve much
better agreement with the truth the high
examination DS here compared to the red
lines the Baseline
ration
okay so as I mentioned that that
example is just wonderful example that
we try to characteriz aor model based on
some indirect measurement data in that
context the error model itself is the
full FEI Reno stress and the indirect
data is just the sparse observation of
the Velocity Fe some of you have noticed
that in that example we use the
assumption that the renal stress Delta
to is a function instead of the resolved
System state the velocity U we assume
that is is a function of spatial
coordinates and more recently there is
extension of that work that extend the
Assumption of renal stress tcer to the
velocity itself and if you are
interested in that extension I highly
recommend to the reference uh list on
the bottom okay I think I see some
questions should I stop and try to
answer them oh it's up to you
um however you want yeah maybe we can
try to answer those questions brief okay
okay um do you want me to okay um
there's a question from suan um in slide
nine I believe that's what he meant by
P9 we see a discrepancy between DNS and
posterior mean value implying that
there's a model form error in
parameterized Ral stress model do you
have any comment on how such error so
the main reason would be kind of the
Restriction that we put here by
combining some basis functions so this
kind of solution space for the data to
may not exactly cover the two you know
discrepency dat to which means that we
still see some mismatch between the
optimal result that we can get and the
true reference the DNS but as I pointed
in many regions we definitely see a
noticeable Improvement compared to the
Baseline range but in order to get
closer to the truth I think what we need
need to do is to propose some more
informative kind of basis functions here
I see there's one more question from
from John on slide nine why is DNS a
single line and not a family of lines
like the
samples oh uh that's
because for each Ensemble here that
means that we use a different choice of
Delta to try to correct
the r modeled renal stress but for the
true renal stress actually it
corresponding to the DS simulation which
means that for DS it will be just kind
of one simulation instead of kind of
many many or some BS yeah there is one
more question from Shady do you want to
answer answer that as well oh yeah yeah
okay uh he asked how often do you assume
measurement data are available is it at
e each time step of the Baseline
over Ah that's a very good question to
clarify that actually we are looking at
the steady case which means that the
measurement data is just taken in space
and we are not considering the unsteady
case and probably that's the confusion
why the DNS is kind of very smooth
looking lines yeah the cour is already
time averaged I see
relevant question from me is that the
sparity of those data in space probably
affect the performance right do you have
any any idea how sparse and how dense
those data need to me yeah that's a
great question so in this work we just
empirically choose those data points
based on our PR knowledge about in which
region Brands perform not well
uh but if we want to kind of do it more
rigorously actually that relate to what
people call Optimal design about the
experiments right okay thank you CH long
no more question for now yeah no worries
okay before starting to the next part I
think I need to plug in the uh Power oh
okay yeah that me right now in case that
I disappear okay sorry about that well
take your
time think we are glad that we had we
had a Q&A session yeah all right go
ahead yeah so then let's move to the
second part of this talk uh imposing
sparcity to Ensemble coming version okay
so as I mentioned in a brief
introduction about eki that one of the
advantage of eki is that the core task
is equivalent to a convex optimization
problem which means that if we want to
further incorporate certain types of
constraints we can do that in the
framework of constraint convex oration
problem okay and in order to illustrate
this point let's think that we introduce
a new variable W it's just the
evaluation of the format and we use this
new variable to augment the existing
Vector of unknown perimeter Theta and
then we will also have a corresponding
forward map that contain both Theta and
G
Theta and with this augumentation we can
formulate a noisy observed dynamical
system in such a way with the augmented
System state with Theta and
W and here the H Matrix is just a
projection Matrix H * V will give us the
W and the orthogonal part of projection
will give us the Theta
so is all this kind of manipulation
about the new system then actually
applying the Ki updating formula every
step is shown as equivalent to solving
the bottom optimization problem so the
reason that is equivalent to solving
this problem is that is equivalent to
apply apping the standard common fter to
this augmented
system and if we take a look at the
optimization problem that we are
actually
solving that contains two
parts and for both terms here the key
feature is that they uh quadratic with
respect to the V Vector here which means
that the obstination problem that we try
to solve although when we apply the eki
updating formula we're not actually
solving this optimization problem we use
that analytical form to give us the next
step estimation about the unknown prins
but this process is equivalent to this
kind of quadratic or convex aimation
problem presented at bottom
and building upon that actually we can
reformate it a little bit for the
objective function to make it more
compatible with the standard form of
quadratic
programming and then imposing sparcity
within eki actually involves that
solving this standard quadratic
programming problem with this L1 penalty
or constraint
okay remember that this projection of V
will give us Theta so what we're looking
at here is just the L1 Norm of the
unknown Theta vector and we want that to
be small so it's smaller or equal to
some constant gamma okay and the good
thing is that we can relate the
constraint of relation specifically
imposing sparcity into Ki with this
equivalent constraint quadratic
programming problem but the only problem
here is that the constraint here is not
the typical
linear inequality which means that we
cannot directly call a existing package
to solve this problem in order to
address this issue we borrow the idea
from the famous paper the Nel paper and
and we try to introduce two
variables uh auxiliary variables B+ and
B minus such that we can parameterize V
and also absolute value of V with this
two auxili variables so they just
correspond to the positive and negative
part of the V
itself and with introducing this
auxiliary variables we can reformulate
the constraint or programming problem
presented in the middle and we have this
kind of final form of the ctive
programming problem associated with the
auxiliary variables v+ and V
minus and the good thing is that with
this kind of transformation we will have
the standard linear inequality which
means that for the bottom problem we can
directly call existing ctive programming
package to solve that and we solve that
as the additional optimization once we
have done each eki updating step okay so
should I stop here to answer a
question uh you can go ahead I don't see
any questions in here in chat yeah okay
yeah so then after introducing the
details of the method let's take a look
at a simple example
so for the true system we studed the
ginski equation so at right hand side of
this equation we can see that we have
three terms and for the model system we
assume that we don't know about the
detail three terms in
the right hand side and we tried to use
linear combination of some redundant
bases and try to figure out what will be
the optimal choices
of the coefficients on coefficients
Alpha and beta sitting in front of those
basis
functions and instead of doing the
calibration of Alpha Beta using the
standard system identification approach
what we assume here is that we only have
access to sometime average data of the U
instead of the time series of U more
specifically we assume that we we have a
few moments of the U autocorrelation of
U and spatial correlation of the system
State U with that we want to see can we
estimate the optimal choice for the
alpha and beta and in this problem is
designed such a way that many components
of Alpha and beta they should be zero
because many bis functions they are just
redundant and we oh sorry you are right
before um I think in for the slide 15
there was question I I missed it uh I he
asked how to check whether this problem
is getting optimized at local Minima or
the global Minima are we using some
graphical method to visualize
it uh that's a reg good question so for
this
one uh we rely upon H the existing
package for the constraint conx
optimization so I would say in most
cases the optimal will be Global optimal
but there are certain cases if we run
into some Singularity issue that might
complicate things but that will manifest
in the estimated
Theta yeah which means that for the
Theta if we plug in into to the forap G
we will see clear difference between the
available data y we
have
okay then let's proceed with the result
part as I mentioned the goal is try to
match this time average data and try to
estimate the unknown parameters Alpha
and
beta and here I just present the uh
results in data space using the
what we call sparse eki and for standard
eki actually it can achieve similar
quality of agreement in the data
space but when we try to simulate the
system calibrate by both method
standardi and SP K and we check the
profile evolved with time as we can see
clearly standard eki show quite
different Behavior than the true system
and and Spar Ki it agrees much better
with the true system and we try to plot
the on N for all the Redundant
coefficients of Alpha and beta and we
found that for sparse C the algorithm
manage to push the l n for all redundant
Bas uh coefficients to Value very close
to zero but that's not the case for
standard account which means that if we
don't introduce sparcity in this case
just because we only have limited amount
of limited uh indirect data we can run
into the
overfitting issue in the data space and
if we simulate the Cali system overfeed
system the result may not agree well
with the true system but for Spar Ki
once we incorporate the sparcity
constraint we manage to resolve this
issue
okay and
so for the rest of the talk I would like
to briefly share some efforts about
going Beyond deterministic
closures so as we mentioned before that
the general goal is try to characterize
difference between F Bar and filda and
for most the existing works we try to
characterize that with a deterministic
ER
term but in some applications
especially for the applications that we
have a kind of not a clear scale
separation that usually happens in many
complex systems that we cannot rely upon
the simple case that if we have clear
scale separation and then for unresolved
scales basically when they aggregate the
effect will not introduce any stac in
the kind of result system but for the
system without a clear scale
separation that assumption might not
hold true anymore that's why we try to
introduce an additional term to
characterize the stcity due to
neglecting those unresolved information
explicit and then actually that relates
to how to chain n the m and sigma more
specifically how to figure out the
unknown parets associated with the m and
sigma function here based on some data
and that relates to the standard problem
about estimating the unknown parameters
in a stochastic differential equation
from some data and there have been
already different directions that can
achieve this goal for example we can use
scamer Mo average to try to read out the
m and sigma directly from time series
data or we can use backward as the or
some stochastic control approach try to
help us optimize the alpha and Gamma un
Co efficients here or we can assume some
uh special structure about problem and
then we can use what we call conditional
gion system try to derive the analytical
form that that can help us solve for the
unknown premes Alpha and Gamma okay but
for our Target we are aiming at a
slightly different
scenario that we assume that we only
have limited amount of indirect data
which means that reading the drift M
term and diffusion s term directly from
the time series data would be impossible
and also we try to use the durative free
optimization method because the
existence of this Winer process will
introduce some difficulty especially
when we have this kind of multiplicative
noise term sitting front it would
introduce Singularity about the gradient
if we want to use some adjoint based
method that's why we
instead just try to stay with the
thetive free optimization method that we
have introduced before The Ensemble
coming
version and let me briefly show uh two
examples that we have done along this
direction the first one is what we
called noisy Lawrence 63 system or true
system it's just the standard Laurence
system plus some
noise and for the model system we assume
that some part within the standard
system is unknown and also the diffusion
coefficient of the noisy system is
unknown to us and we try to jointly
learn these two things based on some
time average data of the system State X1
X2 and
X3 and here I present the result in data
space when we use the stoas term or if
we just don't use theast term just try
to use a deterministic eror term to
characterize difference between the
model system and true
system as we can see here that the
comparison against the true data both of
them show good performance which means
that we can at least match the existing
data in data
space and the natural question would be
does it mean the two models are equally
good in order to answer this question we
try to simulate both calibrated systems
for much longer time and try to plot
what we call inent measure if some of
you are not familiar with this
technology you can just think that is
prob density function for each system
State variable if we simulate the system
for a very long time as we can see that
for the longterm Behavior comparison if
we didn't enable the stochastic term
term and then the inent measure of the
ctive system will be noticeably
different from the true system but if we
joint learn the deterministic ONN term
and also the stochastic term together we
can see that even if we simulate for a
much longer time the r measure or
long-term behavior of the model system
still agrees pretty good whereas the
true system
but as you may see here is just a to
example that the noise is designed to be
in this structure with some winner
process and the next example I'd like to
briefly show in a different setting now
we still focus on our own system but we
are starting the reduce order setting
that for the true or system based on the
results of Professor Palmer about two
decades ago that if we do some pod
transformation we can transform this
system to a new coordinat such that the
third dimension carries least energy so
it approximately carries about 5% of the
system energy which means that if we
want to build a reduce order Model A
straightforward thought would be let's
just throw away this third dimension of
course is just carry a tiny amount of
the system energy rate let's just get
rid of it and then we will have a
two-dimensional
system but in the original work of
Professor Palmer he found that that if
we Sim reduce order system the chaotic
Behavior basically disappear which means
that the redu order system cannot
characterize the true behavior of the am
system but more interestingly he showed
that if we just introduce some Ren noise
just white noise and then we can get the
chaotic Behavior back at least
qualitatively so in spite of this kind
of interesting phenomena we try to
instead of just adding some empirical
white noise into the reduce order model
we try to add both the terministic and
the stochastic model into the reduce
order model and we try to estimate M1 M2
Sigma one and sigma 2 more specific the
the unknown perimeters associated with
the models based on some time average
data of A1 and
A2 and at bottom here I just show the
key results of the this example that if
we try to calibrate the M1
M2 Sigma 1 Sigma 2 terms based on some
time average statistics of A1 and A2 and
we plug in the Cali model and simulate
the system for a much longer time and
compare the in measure against the true
invariant measure of A1 and we2 instead
of just getting a qualitative chaotic
Behavior back for the calibr system if
we use data to help us calibrate more
sophisticated stochastic model we can
get qualitative agreement in the
long-term behavior for the reduce order
system so with that I would like to
Briefly
summarize what we have presented here
the first is that many complex dynamical
systems involve multiscale
Dynamics without a clear scale
separation for which numerically
resolving all the scills is too
expensive and closure modeling is needed
when simulating those systems and also
it demonstrated the learning of closures
based on indirect data it can be sparse
of relation space or it can be time
average statistics of your time series
System state using Ensemble coming
version and I want to emphasize that
just because it is a dtive free
optimization method we don't need to
access the gradient information of your
forward model G and also sparcity
constraint can help avoid overfeeding in
the learning of culture models when only
indirect data is available and the
amount of data is
limited and finally we demonstrate that
durative free common inversion method is
also enable the learning of stochastic
closures using indirect data so for
those who are interested in exploring
more about the common inversion meths
that I mentioned here so at bottom I
just attach a link about the package of
different coming version methods that
was developed and maintained by the CLA
group at CCH so with that I'm happy to
take questions thank you thank you so
much Jong that was a wonderful
insightful talk um yeah let's let's have
a Q&A sessions um I can start
um it's you know the if you go back to
slide
14 um you introduced like augumentation
of new variable right um I I forgot the
notation for the new
variable uh but um W right um to make
the eki as an compx
optimization yeah problem is is it
well-known um result I'm not familiar
with the emble common inversion that's
um
maybe yeah the first work that uh
systematically summarize this kind of
equivalency I would see can be found in
this reference so it came out in
2019 19 see so it's not I guess not long
ago like three years ago four years ago
yeah interesting and also can you um
comment about those this computational
cost of eki in
general uh that's a great
question yeah so in general the the eki
just because we're using the updating
formula here it is an assemble based
method which means that we need to run a
bunch of Ensemble simulation
specifically for the forward map G here
uh as long as we can kind of have kind
of parallel Computing resources just
because each for evaluation here is more
like kind of isolated so which means
that they can be done in a parallel way
and another kind of expensive part here
is some of you may notice is the Matrix
inversion
here and the good thing is that for this
work we only focus on the limited amount
of data remember that uh the kind of
inversion we perform here actually
corres responding to the dimension of
the data space so for the limited amount
data this kind of Matrix inversion
usually it will not cause any trouble we
can just use some naive Matrix inversion
on some kind of regular machines but in
the situation that if we want
to perform kind of similar method and in
a high dimensional data space and then
we need to be careful about the
efficiency of this matric inversion here
but the good thing is that the gamma
here is just diagonal matrix in many
cases and the Corr Matrix here as long
as we introduce some localization
technique it can be a sparse Matrix so
which means that the efficiency of
extending this method to large scale
scale problem involve the efficiency of
solving the inversion of sparse
Matrix awesome yeah very nice
um slide eight
yeah what what is the motivation of
choosing prior as
ation process Gan process as a prior
choosing process as a prior
yeah that's a good question so one
motivation is that we want to ensure
some smoothness about the
sampled
datta and if we just assume gion process
and if we use Square exponential kernel
and then the sample kind of Delta to we
can ensure the smoothness of that so
that's kind of one one uh physical prior
we want to
incorporate uh another reason that we
rely upon ction is that it's less
expensive so if we want to kind of
sample from more sophisticated kind of
stochastic process it tends to be more
expensive it's like a a tradeoff yeah
yeah those are the computational reason
and the smoothness reason
but um what if the prior is not actually
Gan um so if the prior is not actually
Gan uh I would
say instead of directly someing from
that PRI because some nonan PRI can be
very expensive to directly simple ways
maybe we can try to
map Gan to to nonan so along that
direction so the nonan prior generation
because prior is more about some kind of
modeling choices yeah if we really have
the kind of physical justification to
justify some nonan prior I have seen
relevant work just focusing on nonan
prior Generation by using against the
generative seral Network basically you
have the mapping from the low
dimensional gion random Vector to high
dimensional non gion random vector and
then the mapped non gion Vector can be
used as the sample from your nan PR
interesting
interesting okay thank you so much Jin
Long um is there any questions from
audience and they' been diligent asking
you question question during the talk
so I'm happy to answer questions they
are all very good
questions
yeah I guess I guess they don't have
questions I'm I'm well
but still you can ask um questions in
Long by emailing
um um and yeah I'm I'm sure zong is Will
be very happy to have any questions via
email um and also um some collaboration
I
guess you will be happy you will be
happy to have a collaboration yeah with
some folks and oh there questions from
abinav does eki works for high
dimensional
problems yeah so I think that relate to
uh partly relate to one question that we
briefly disc discuss the competition
limitation here as I mention if we have
a high
dimensional perimeter space that would
not cause much issue because here is
just kind of high dimensional Matrix
Vector multiplication but if the data
space is high dimensional and then the
Matrix inversion here can hurt us if we
just use naive f kind of Standard
General Matrix inversion techniques but
as I mentioned as long as we introduce
some localization about this cence
Matrix because anyway we estimate this
cence based on The Ensemble and usually
we don't have enough kind of Ensemble to
estimate all the cence which means that
we can just focus on what we can
estimate in a relatively accurate way
localize that Corr structure and just
kind of threshold other kind of long
range
cence and in that way this Matrix
becomes a SP Matrix and in order to
really generalize this method to very
high dimensional data space as long as
we can have efficient sparse Matrix
large sparse Matrix inversion algorithm
we can apply them here it will be a
separate kind of
Direction a asked again localization
means to reduce the
dimensionality localization means that
if we estimate this current Matrix that
will be the dimension of data space
times dimension of data space and
actually some of the off diagonal terms
we don't have enough information to
estimate them uh accurately and then we
can just threshold those kind of long
range cerence which means that we just
keep those kind of short range cerence
information and introduce many zeros in
other parts of the Matrix yeah a a way
of
specifying that's C
mg Matrix um any other
question
well if not let's thank our speaker Jin
Long for very insightful and um
wonderful talk um very nice um apprciate
it you yeah yeah thank you very much for
the invitation and all the questions
thanks thank you for the nice talk all
right um let's end here y bye